the new york city skyline where it looks
as though it's business as usual a rare
day when the mets and yankees collide in
their hometowns each and on a day where
baseball celebrates number 42
with racial equality on the forefront of
everyone's mind tonight the league pays
tribute to the legacy of a
larger-than-life baseball and societal
pioneer game one for the yankees it's a
left-hander on the mound and jordan
montgomery out there for the first time
since august 17th to make his fifth
start of the year two balls and two
strikes to jeff mcneil
and a strikeout starts the game for
jordan montgomery here's jd davis now
he's been a bright spot in 2020
another strikeout for montgomery so two
gone and that'll bring up the right
fielder michael conforto
and jordan montgomery is struck out the
side the yankees will square off against
the 29 year old veteran right-hander
michael walk up here's clint frazier now
with void aboard
frazier sends the ball into the gap in
left center field that's going to chase
jake mariznick
you see how aggressively they play it
with floyd there's the answer to your
question he's being waved around to
score he'll do so without a play
and before and outs on the board in the
bottom of the first the yankees have a
one-nothing lead
here's brett gardner now with a runner
at second gardner with a punt and a
dandy
here's gary sanchez now the next 3-2 to
sanchez and he loses him on vault for a
ball that gets away from ramos that
allows frazier to score two-nothing
yankees
oh boy this one could not have started
any worse for the mets and there were
two away so now it's devon floreal who
makes his major league debut in this one
today
a name that yankee fans have been aware
of for the past couple of years
certainly regarded as one of their top
talents one of their top prospects
falling two strikes to him with two runs
in
gets him again on that same pitch pete
alonso will lead things off in the
second
four straight strikeouts to open the
game for jordan
montgomery trying to get to the pitch
down
off balance
and the mets simply are not picking up
that change up from montgomery and again
that high release point
i mean it may take them once through the
lineup to adjust to this wilson ramos
now with canoe aboard
there it is fifth strikeout of the game
clint fraser now batting with a runner
in scoring position
frazier sends a ball well hit to right
and that one's gonna go
an rbi double and a two run homer for
clint frazier i told you i like this
matchup coming into the game
not talking in the lefty but frazier
right-handed hitter against waka first
time fastball this time cutter these
right-handed yankee hitters hitting here
each day no to get the ball out right
field gary sanchez here in the third for
the home team against walking a lot of
the damage by voight and frazier
challenges him with 95 top of the strike
zone and gets him to swing right through
it fort okay to continue for the time
being he's in scoring position now for
miguel and duhar
got him swinging that's six for michael
walka tonight on florio strikeout victim
in his first major league at bat here's
the 3-2 and he goes to the change-up and
gets the strikeout
see if alonso turns it loose right here
a little more aggressive montgomery's
1-2
and he strikes out alonso
[Applause]
three fourth and that's going to load
the bases with two gun here in the
fourth
the two out trouble spot here for the
reliever walter lockett he gave up the
single to luke voight a walk to clint
frazier and then he hit brett gardner so
the bases are loaded now for gary
sanchez
and he strikes out gary sanchez on a
nice breaking ball to get out of the fix
so the first legitimate rally the mets
have enjoyed all game long here's a med
rosario now and that one spiked smith's
able to score and that's how the mets
finally push across a run
and rosario bounces it to first a great
play by four to first base just in time
to get rosario we're going to stay here
because it looked like ahmed rosario
might have gotten his foot down first i
think he did and yes it does replay
review powered by mitel and it does go
the mets away rosario's safe
and that means runners at the corners
with sugan full count pitch
and mcneil flips a little fly ball into
shallow right
out there to get it is estrada to wrap
up the inning started talking about
esteban florio his route to the big
leagues being slowed down by injuries
into center field and there's his first
major league hit
welcome to the big leagues
estevon floreal
back-to-back singles put runners aboard
and get jordan montgomery into an
awkward spot that means they go to the
bullpen do the yankees for one of their
best snuffers of rallies and that's the
right-hander chad green alonso
representing the tying run late full
count pitch
into center field and well hit florial
back turns his back to the infield and
it's gone
pete alonso
has hit a three-run home run to tie it
in the sixth well 3-2 you don't want to
miss high and this pitch is too much
belt high instead of up sanchez's glove
is higher but ball doesn't quite get
there struggling against the fastball
that has to feel so good
to not just square up a fastball by chad
green's fastball dominic smith now it
makes it even more interesting
as smith sends a ball out to center and
that one's gone
dom smith with a home run the mets grab
their first lead of the game
just never has gotten runway to do it
jake mariznick sends a ball to the left
and that one's gone
the third home run of the inning for the
mets
mariznick's first as a met yeah it's
just a cement picture he jumped on it
three home run hitting off chad green
edwin diaz takes over looking to close
things down for the mets in the last of
the seventh
swinging a miss at the big velocity from
diaz jordan mercer finished the year
strong with the tigers last year he
strikes out and that's two strikeouts
for diaz
and that'll do it edwin diaz strikes out
the side with an exclamation point and a
five run sixth the mets take game one of
the doubleheader tonight